a warning this report from our moscow
correspondent anna magnay includes
parts of those telephone calls in which
vera can be heard
pleading for help some people may find
it upsetting to hear
last year in this siberian apartment
block vera peshteleva was murdered by
her ex-boyfriend
she was a 23 year old student just come
to pick up her things
the neighbors called for help seven
times but no one came
when they finally broke the door down it
was too late
at the hearing we attended the judge
read out one hundred and eleven injuries
inflicted on pechetelever over hours
before vladislav kanyos finally
strangled her with the cord from an iron
her uncle sat just feet away from the
man who killed her
um
um
foreign
last month the audio recordings went
viral only then was a criminal
negligence charge brought against the
call center operators as well as the
police
and the potential penalties for them and
for kanye's increased
this is a horrific case but it is in no
way a one-off
russia suffers a plague of domestic
violence concealed behind closed doors
and what unites most of those cases is
the weak response of the state
and law enforcement
in the same city of camerover we meet
ruslan mellon
he's a surgeon specializing in face and
neck traumas
he knows better than anyone what
domestic violence looks like
and so he draws it each face each
horrific set of injuries
each with its own story
youtube
and this kind of violence do you think
this is just the nature of things
is there nothing you think that the law
or the state
or civil society can do yes
in 2017 russia decriminalized first
instance domestic assault so as long as
there are no bones broken
it isn't a crime
it's not as though society doesn't care
this is a new talk show all about
domestic violence hosted by margherita
gretcheba
well known now after her ex-husband cut
off her hands
in a fit of jealous rage
but the leading advocacy group nacillio
or no to violence
which helped produce this play featuring
gretchev's story
has just been labelled a foreign agent
because even as civil society tries to
look forward
russia has a leadership which looks back
and without a systematic response to the
problem of domestic violence
from parliament to the courts to the
police russia's women will continue to
die
dynamagne sky news camerova russia
you